>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Saundra Smith McBee:
It is my honor today
to introduce Mr. Paul Rudnick.
Mr. Rudnick is an American
playwright, novelist,
screenwriter and essayist.
His plays have been produced both on
and off Broadway and
around the world.
Rudnick was born and
raised in Piscataway,
New Jersey where his
mother Selma was a publicist
and his father Norman
was a physicist.
Rudnick attended Yale College
before moving to New York City
where he wrote his book jacket
copy and worked as an assistant
to his friend, the costume
designer, William Ivey Long.
Rudnick began writing for
magazines including Esquire,
Vogue, Vanity Fair, and Spy.
Rudnick's first play
was Poor Little Lambs,
a comedy about a female
Yale student's attempt
to join the Whiffenpoufs, an
All-American male singing group.
The play's cast included
the young then Kevin Bacon,
Bronson Pinchot and Blanche Baker.
Rudnick then wrote two novels,
Social Disease, A Satiric Tale
of New York's Nightlife in the
vein of Evelyn Waugh's Vile Bodies
and I'll Take It which was a tribute
to Rudnick's mother and aunts
and their passionate
love of shopping.
In the late 1980's Rudnick
moved into the top floor
of a Greenwich Village brownstone
which had once been the 1920's home
of the actor, John Barrymore.
That inspired Rudnick's play I Hate
Hamlet about a young TV star who
and he's about to play Hamlet is
visited by the ghost of Barrymore.
In 1993, Rudnick had a breakthrough
with his off-Broadway hit Jeffrey.
Rudnick has won an Obie award,
an Outer Critics Circle award
and the John Gassner
Playwright award.
Rudnick's later plays
included the Naked Eye,
which depicted an extreme
photographer along the lines
of Robert Mapplethorpe.
Rudnick has worked as an
accredited script doctor
on movies including the Addams
Family and The First Wives Club.
In 2011, HarperCollins
published I Shudder,
a collection of Rudnick's
autobiographical essays,
some covering his work
on stage and screen.
Since 1998, Rudnick has
been a frequent contributor
to the New Yorker, mostly of
over 50 short humor pieces.
His work appears in the collections
of Fierce Pajamas and
Disquiet, Please.
In May 2013, scholastic
published Gorgeous,
Rudnick's first adult novel.
Publishers Weekly in
a starred review said
that the book was hilarious,
profane, and profiled.
And in January 2016, his
latest book scholastic publish,
It's all Your Fault, New York Times
says, caution do not read in public,
will cause you to laugh
and maybe cry out loud.
Everyone please help me welcome
to the stage Mr. Paul Rudnick.
[ Applause ]
>> Paul Rudnick: Oh thank you
for that wonderful introduction,
oops that wonderful introduction
and thank all of you so much
for being here and thank you.
I was told that at these talks
the absolute worst sin was
to read anything from cards or
notes, so I'm not going to do that.
So here goes.
What I wanted to talk about today
was probably the most common
question that writers always get,
which is where do you
get your ideas from.
And I had immediately thought
of so many awful answers to that
like Walmart or you steal them.
But what I found and I think this
happens to a lot of other writers
as well is if you're
yearning to write something
and the rent is due you'll often
try to do something like sit
down with your notebook open
and make lists and try to figure
out okay, what's a great
idea, what should I do next.
Usually those ideas vanish instantly
even if they feel sort of wonderful
and inspired at the moment, they
somehow just don't take hold.
What I find is there has
to be something in my life
and in the larger world
that becomes so overwhelming
that it insists on
being written about.
It can be personal or it can be
larger than that, but it's something
where you find yourself helplessly
drawn to it and you just have
to start writing whether
you like it or not.
So I wanted to share kind
of three brief moments
of that sort of inspiration.
The first actually
which was mentioned
in the introduction was years ago
when I first moved to New York
and this will show you
how long ago this was
because it involves real estate.
This was when if you wanted an
apartment you could actually look
at the real estate listings in the
New York Times or the Village Voice,
wander over to a building,
take a look, wait a day
or so before deciding
to pay the very low rent
and there you have an apartment.
This has been unheard of for
about the past 30 years now.
But when I first arrived, I saw a
listing I think it was in the Times
that intrigued me because
it said medieval duplex.
And I thought okay, what's
medieval about it, you know,
is it the plumbing,
is it the landlord.
So immediately I went
and it was the top floor
of a brownstone right
off Washington Square.
So it was the romantic ideal
of every young artist
moving to New York.
It was a garret basically,
but a very nice one
with the full top floor and it had
been the nest of John Barrymore,
the famous actor who lived there
actually beginning at around 1901,
when he was playing
Hamlet on Broadway.
And he remodeled the
whole place as something
which he called the
alchemist's corner.
So it really had the most
marvelous enchanted feeling.
There were stained-glass windows
and an enormous skylight and up
on the roof there was
a tiny cottage.
Which from my research I found
out Barrymore had planted the entire
roof and added a reflecting pool,
all of which was not up to
code, so it eventually collapsed
into the apartment below.
But that had been repaired
by the time I got there.
So I looked around with
a real estate agent
and I was immediately drawn to
it, but I wasn't quite sure.
So that I went home and I
called my very first agent,
this wonderful woman named Helen
Merrill, who even then was already
in her 70's and very German.
She moved to Germany
before the war as a refugee,
but still had the thickest accent.
And I said Helen, I'm
looking at this apartment
with this Barrymore
pedigree and she said,
oh Rudnick perhaps you
have found my hairpins.
Because it turned out that
Helen had had an affair
with Barrymore's son-in-law
on the premises.
So at that point it sort of
became impossible not to write
about the apartment
once I had moved in.
And I began writing a novel
that was called I Hate Hamlet
because somehow it felt
like a literary Greenwich
Village thing to do.
But eventually because it was
about actors and it was all set
in a single room it became a
play, I just let it happen.
And it eventually ended
up on Broadway in a sort
of wildly adventurous
and traumatic run
because what happened
was we cast this insane,
oops oh this insane wildly alcoholic
English actor named Nicol Williamson
was playing the ghost
of John Barrymore.
And he was the kind of guy who
the first time I met him was
at a restaurant where the table was
filled with two empty wine bottles,
a can of beer, a few cocktails
and because he was so known
as a drunkard when someone asked,
are you still drinking he
said no, not in months.
And there was that moment
where you thought do we point
to the glassware, you know, and I
just thought I hope for the best.
And Nicol on his good
nights could be inspired
and the play just soared.
And on his lesser nights the first
act ended with a big climactic dual,
a sword fight that took
place all over the stage.
And Nicol's costar was the very
young actor named Evan Handler,
who you may know from Sex
in the City and all sorts
of television things and Evan was
wonderful, wonderful, very talented
and wonderfully patient as well.
But Nicol did not want any costar,
let alone one who was
much younger than he was.
Nicol had called me one
morning at 3 a.m. to tell me
that he felt he could
play both leading roles.
It's one of those questions
where you don't know do I
ask how you would do that,
how you would have a
sword fight with yourself.
But Nicol took it into his head
and then one night during the run,
during the sword fight he
took after Evan for real
and stabbed him and drew blood.
And I was not there that evening,
but the next day I came downstairs
and the full front page of the
New York Post said, I hit Hamlet,
star stabs actor in the butt,
which if you know the paper it's
sort of New York Post poetry.
So with that kind of experience
from that moment of walking
into an apartment I never
knew where this was headed,
but I knew I had to write about it.
So that was my first moment of okay
inspiration appears from anywhere.
The next thing I'd like to
get into was more serious
and affected far more people,
which was by that point we were
into late 80's, early 90's and I
was a gay man living in New York.
And so many people, an overwhelming
amount of people I knew were sick
or dying of AIDS and it
was a terrifying time.
This was before there
were any treatments.
This was while the government was
completely ignoring the illness.
This was where even medical
personnel were unwilling sometimes
to treat or touch people
who were infected.
And because I'm a comic writer
at that time I couldn't imagine
that I had any place in
writing about the plague years
and about the people I knew,
it just felt like the
most awful contradiction.
But then one day, actually it was
also mentioned in my introduction,
a dear friend of mine,
William Ivey Long,
who is a true Southern gentleman
and a brilliant Tony
award-winning costume designer.
He and I were going to the hospital
to visit another good friend
of ours named Eric who was
very, very ill and would die.
And Eric was emaciated,
was hallucinating,
and also his room was quarantined.
It was still the most --
everything about it only got worse.
But Eric what was so strange
is Eric had many friends,
so he must have been
visited quite a bit.
But he was refusing to
kind of live up to his role
as a noble sick person
and why should he.
But Eric was doing things like
demanding exactly the right shade
of towels in the right
amount of Egyptian cotton.
And if you brought him a
beverage it had to be, you know,
grape-ade not lime-ade,
not lemonade.
If you brought him the fashion
magazines that he loved they had
to be French Vogue and Italian Vogue
because American Vogue was trashy.
So he became so insistent
on everything
and nothing was ever good enough
and of course, because he was
in such a terrible state we wanted
to please him and do anything
to ease what he was going through.
But that morning, that visit William
and I went out to a park bench
in front of the hospital
afterwards after a couple
of hours of being be harangued.
And William turned
to me and he said,
you know I love Eric very dearly
and I will do anything for him,
but my God I want to slap him.
And we both looked at each other
and the whole situation was
so unbearably awful and tragic
that all we could do
was burst out laughing.
And I realized that so many of
the people I knew were getting
through all of this with the
only weapon in their possession,
which was a sense of humor.
That people were marching
and people were helping
and people were joining Act Up
and every possible organization,
but these were some of
the most stylish and funny
and extraordinary people
I've ever met.
Men and women, gay and straight,
it just was something to behold.
And I thought oh okay that's
what I want to write about.
And that moment and all of the
stuff that seems impossible and all
of the stuff that somehow becomes
hilarious in the face of death.
So I wrote this play
called Jeffrey and it was
about a guy -- it was funny again.
Again, it was a character that
began in another play I was working
on about another sort
of story entirely.
But there was this one guy who
was giving up sex who said well
that was the only possible way to
deal with the AIDS crisis was kind
of to run from it and to
run from romance and to run
from any kind of personal contact.
And that seemed like
a strong storyline,
so that became the center.
And once I'd written the play
Helen my agent again submitted
to every theater in New York,
all of whom turned it down.
Even the people who liked it
would write me letters saying,
oh well I enjoyed this, our
audience would never stand for it.
It just became known - they said how
can you have a comedy about AIDS.
And Helen finally went
to a tiny theater
on 23rd Street called the WPA
and she sat outside the
artistic director's office
and would not leave
till he read the play.
And then wouldn't leave
until he agreed to do it.
So the man named Kyle
Renick who was wonderful
and I was just so grateful.
So it was set for like
a three-week run.
Every actor New York was
warned away from this play.
They were told it would
ruin their careers.
They were told it was far too gay.
And it was -- the worst thing
you can do to actors is try
to scare them about
completely ridiculous concerns.
So the people we ended up with I
just was so deeply grateful for.
They were so talented and that
they were willing to show up.
So we did the play and I remember,
you know, a terrible dress rehearsal
and then the first preview was on
New Year's Eve for some odd reason.
And it went really well and my mom
was there, I was sitting behind her.
And when my mom would watch things
her shoulders would be kind of up
around her ears until the audience
started laughing and responding
and then they gradually settled,
which meant things were okay.
But I was flooded with of what I
always think of as the highest form
of happiness which is relief.
And the play opened it was very
well received and became --
people just flocked to it
because there was a sense of,
it was almost like a town meeting
where these were matters that were
on everyone's mind and no
one was sure how to respond
and no one was sure if
it was okay to laugh.
And the play kind of made that
understandable at the very least.
And it moved on, it ran off
Broadway for about a year.
And I was just so -- it the first
thing I'd ever written where I felt
that my voice was completely
heard and that I was proud
of the work that I'd done.
And I was then told by many
people oh this play will be done
in New York, maybe LA or San
Francisco, but nowhere else.
And then it was produced
all around the world.
And so again, it just felt
like this, you know, gift.
Although what was odd was I remember
in some other countries they would
change the title and I remember
for some reason in Paris
they changed the title
to Sex, Drugs and Sequins.
Actually I like productions of my
play in languages I don't speak
because I don't have
to worry about them.
I just assume they're going well.
But so it was -- again, it was
such a lesson in okay write
about something that scares
you, write about the thing
that is most critical to
your life aside from writing.
Write about something that
might actually matter to people.
And the fact that that the audiences
were responding just meant the world
to me and it just opened
everything up for me.
Then the third thing I'd like to
talk about is my first venture
into YA, which was with the help
of my Scholastic, my
wonderful publisher.
Because what I wanted to write about
was beauty in every possible sense.
Why it doesn't matter
in the slightest,
why it can affect everyone's
lives helplessly.
And I'd been offered a
number of projects set
in fashion worlds and
that kind of thing.
I was also one of the writers on
the movie of the Devil Wears Prada.
There are often on films there
are a batch of writers and woman,
Aline Brosh McKinna, who was
credited did a magnificent job.
And she I think borrowed certain
elements from everybody's draft,
but it ended up being
very much her work.
But it was a wonderful
introduction to that world.
And I had also written at
Vogue and had met Anna Wintour
who is an extraordinary person.
And I thought okay, what's the
way into this world, you know,
what is it just froth, how do
you make it somehow larger.
And then my mom became very ill, she
was diagnosed with ovarian cancer
and went through the whole
process of chemotherapy,
doctor visits, you name it.
Although I think something that
pleased my mother enormously,
my partner, John, is
here who's a physician
and my cousin Carl is also a doctor.
So my mom would go to
the doctor accompanied
by two handsome young doctors.
So this was kind of
Jewish mom nirvana for her.
And it was sort of
wonderful to watch.
But I was going through
this with her
and there were two things
that really struck me.
One, she was going through a lot of
clippings and mementos from her past
and she found I think
during the war,
during the second world war she
actually had written an advice
column and there was a photo of
a very young version of my mom
at the top of each column.
And she looked at it and she said,
you know back then I thought I was
so ugly and she said and I looked
great and then she laughed.
And it was both horribly
sad and joyous
because my mom had an
incredible sense of humor.
And what happened after that was
during the chemo she lost all
her hair.
And probably right before she was
about to lose it all when she knew
that was upon her I found
through William Ivey Long a
theatrical hairstylist who worked
on Phantom of the Opera,
Hairspray, a lot of shows.
He came to her apartment
and shaved her head,
which gave it a certain flair.
And she said that somehow
allowed her
to accept what was
going on a bit more.
And then after the chemo
her hair grew back.
And she prefaced this by saying all
the women in my mother's family,
a lot of them were
librarians and teachers
and they were extraordinary women
and sort of very strict minded
and they all had hair all the way
down their backs which they kept
in buns, tightly tied at
the nape of their necks.
That was the proper
way to do things.
They thought anything fussy or
any visits to the beauty parlor,
let alone any highlighting
was considered vain
and prideful and ultimately gentile.
So they stayed far away.
So my mom throughout her entire
life had had only one very severe
hairstyle, which she
looked beautiful
but it was still that was the rule.
So after her hair grew back
it was still very short,
but it was also wonderfully
curly and brilliantly silver.
And when she looked at it she
became so joyful, she just laughed
and she had just never allowed
herself that sort of personal moment
to enjoy how she looked and it came
out of the worst possible
circumstances.
So that sense of the power
of beauty and the burden
of beauty was what
inspired my book Gorgeous.
And it was the first --
well actually it wasn't the first
time I had ever sort of wandered
into fantasy because certainly
I Hate Hamlet had a ghost.
But what I thought of was and it
was something that also took a while
to land in terms of was it a
play, was it a film about a girl
from a very small town
in Appalachia,
grew up in a trailer park whose mom
was morbidly obese and who dies.
And sort of tells her
daughter right before she dies
that something wonderful is going
to happen and when it does she needs
to say yes and she needs to accept
the magic that's going to appear.
And the girl then receives all
sorts of mysterious messages.
She's flown to New York where she
meets a very powerful and not all
that pleasant, but clearly very
gifted Manhattan designer named Tom
Kelly who makes her an offer.
He says, I will make you three
dresses, one red, one white
and one black and if you agree
to wear them you will become
the most beautiful woman
who has ever lived.
And at first she thinks
this is of course nonsense.
Then she decides no, her mother's
deathbed wish was say yes,
so she does and he does
and that's what happens
in the rest of the book.
So it's this very wild
and comic adventure,
but it's with very
serious underpinnings
about what does it mean for this
girl who's very smart and very savvy
and she sees how beauty works in the
world and she sees how money works
and celebrity and everything
that's very alluring
and can seem very important
and can be quite destructive.
But because I thought no,
I want this girl to win.
She figures out how to kind of
lasso the power of all that.
And she -- well if you read the
book you'll -- I'll just one thing,
she does end up as
the Queen of England.
So again, it was an idea that sort
of had circled for a long time
and then finally landed
with the help of all
of these very powerful
events in my life.
So I think if I was ever
going to give advice
to writers, which I should never do.
But I think sometimes people you
could tie yourself up in knots
and think oh my God I'm not a
writer, I don't know what to do
with myself, everything I do sours.
And I think no, it will find you, at
least that's been the case with me.
That that's been the joy of my
life and it can drive you mad
because you sometimes think oh my
God I'll never have another idea
again, nothing will ever
descend and then suddenly.
It's interesting my most current
projects after the recent massacre
in Orlando a new play just
sort of poured out of me
and completely unexpected.
Again, it was one of those things
where I thought oh my God this
is the worst kind of tragedy and
yet I want to find something
celebratory in the world's response
to that and something both tormented
and ultimately healing in some way.
So that is now underway.
And beyond that I of course,
got a call a few days ago
from the New Yorker saying, Paul
we need something about Brad
and Angelina by Thursday.
And that's the kind
of challenge I like.
Also, the trouble is
when you get a request
like that you think this is
what we call a developing story.
So I thought, you know, okay and
also it's so odd when I write things
like that for the New Yorker
that are often very contemporary
and you're dealing with.
And you suddenly start to
think wait, I don't want to,
you know want to attack
Brad and Angelina.
I thought the world is
doing plenty of that.
On the other hand, it's
playing out on this, you know,
on every possible form of
social media and it's delicious.
And you also think just why do
movie stars ever marry each other,
you know, just haven't
they read the tabloids
about the person they're marrying.
You know, can they
ever be surprised.
And you sort of admire the
noble belief in oh yeah,
this time it's going to work out.
And on the other hand you think
okay, you're ignoring everything.
But so it was juicy stuff.
So if you read the New Yorker
next week you'll see what emerged
because I tried to find an angle
on it because you think okay,
you don't want to sort of
straight-ahead almost never works
because then it's not funny, it's
not personal, it's not fresh.
So I finally kind of
with that time pressure.
It's also why I love writing for
the New Yorker is because with plays
and books and films you could take
years towards the final product
and sometimes it can
still evaporate.
But with the New Yorker you write
it and there you get to see it
and the world gets to comment
on it for better or for worse.
And that's a real excitement and
I grew up reading the New Yorker,
so I feel, you know, wonderfully
grateful to be included there.
So anyway, that's how for me
at least that's how
ideas sort of approach.
So now if anyone has any questions
I'd be happy to answer them.
Anybody? Go ahead, come
on pretend I'm Lois Lowry.
Pretend I'm that rich.
And that one from -- yes.
>> How would you like create your
humor because like I try to write
like humorous stuff and it comes
out like of the ha-ha-ha moments.
>> Paul Rudnick: Yeah the question,
that's a very good question
about how do you write humor.
I find I come from a family
that really valued humor,
so you know at the dinner
table, all that stuff.
It was just an, unending
sense of comedy.
And that there was
always also a sense
that humor was a great
balance wheel if you started
to take yourself too seriously
or feel a little too smug
that somebody could sort
of land a choice punchline
and that would take care of you.
But I think the best
way is maybe don't try
to deliberately write
comedy, write about the story
and the characters you're
interested in and if they're going
to be funny that will happen.
That in a way the comedy
sometimes will take care
of itself so that you can.
It's especially hard I think when
you're writing books and things
to wonder, will people
laugh at this.
You can lose yourself
is any of this funny,
is this awful or is this hilarious.
So I think it's one
of the few things
where you don't have
to worry it to death.
You know, think sometimes
something I'll write
that I would imagine was very
serious, then when it's read aloud
or somebody or it becomes
a play it's hilarious
and sometimes I'm not even
sure why they're laughing,
but I'm very happy that they do.
So yeah, I would say don't
beat yourself up about comedy,
you know, let it find you.
>> Thank you.
>> Paul Rudnick: You're
welcome, thank you.
>> Mr. Rudnick I only know
your work from the New Yorker,
although I'm eager to
read it in other forms.
And I just wanted to say
that I loved the piece you did
recently called My Demands.
And hope that Leah Ellen
Altschuler and the whole --
everybody, the whole
campus at the Shower
of Blessings Junior Bible
College will come to life
in some form whether it's in
more pieces in the New Yorker,
a book or a movie or a play.
But I wanted to say that
what I loved about it was
that you took a character
who I at least
and probably many other New Yorker
readers might have dismissed as,
you know, according to
our preconceived notions
of what she would be like
and you showed real
compassion and love for her.
And so that's why I want
to know more about her.
>> Paul Rudnick: Oh well
thank you, I'm so glad.
This was a piece, it's funny
actually my most recent YA book
from Scholastic It's All Your Fault
deals with a similar character,
a girl who was homeschooled
and brought up in sort
of a deeply religious and
deeply devout atmosphere.
And I thought, you know, it's easy
to use those people as targets,
especially if you're
from the East Coast.
And I thought no that wears itself
out in about, you know,
two sentences.
So I thought -- because
actually the people I know
who have been homeschooled are
some of the most sweet natured,
genuinely innocent people because
they haven't been socialized
in the American public school system
where you get bullied and beaten
up all the time and you
kind of learn to, you know,
develop a very sometimes
too thick skin.
So that these -- even
as adults a lot
of homeschooled people have
a genuine sort of optimism
about them that I really admire.
And in that case with that piece
it was also about what's going
on all the time on today's campuses,
trigger warnings and safe spaces
and that whole sense of students.
Because my heart go -- I think the
students are often absolutely right
or crazily wrong, but I think no,
no, no that's what that college life
and that age is all about.
I think you are allowed to
say absurd and strident things
and find your way in the world.
At the same time your heart goes
out to the professors
who have to deal with.
There was that one student at Yale
who kept howling at a professor
that she didn't want
to hear him talk,
she just wanted to
talk about her pain.
And then someone of
course, mentioned you come
from a very nice neighborhood, you
know, I don't know where quite --
was the pain involving dry-cleaning.
But it was -- so I thought again,
that's such rich comic turf
because it's, you know, it's
like the current election.
You know, when you've got so
many opinionated people howling
at each other they're
usually very funny.
Yes.
>> My question is out of everything
you've ever written what is the
finished product that was the
most different from the idea
that initially inspired it
or your first conception
of what it would look like?
>> Paul Rudnick: That --
it's an interesting question.
Everything I tried -- one
thing I've learned sort
of in a hard way manner
is to let it surprise me.
So things often start
quite differently.
It's funny there was -- well
one thing that happened once
when I was called in to overhaul
the First Wives Club the movie.
And when I was -- the script I was
given there had been many drafts was
very serious believe it or
not given the final movie.
And I remember one of the features
of it if you've seen the film,
Diane Keaton has a daughter
in it who is a lesbian.
And in the original draft that
character was mentally disabled
and she was the word back then used
was retarded and they said Paul,
could you please make this
character into a lesbian.
And I kind of by of course
being an idiot I first said,
well why not both.
But it was just the
most absurd leap,
but on the other hand they had these
wonderful stars and I went to work
and the movie was about
to start shooting.
And I thought okay, how do
you turn this tragic story
of these women who'd been
treated badly by their husbands
and abandoned into this
sort of powerful statement
about these women's friendship
and revenge and Manhattan lives.
So it -- and when, it's a
tribute to the film's producer,
a guy named Scott Rudin who's
a genius because it was --
the whole shoot was insane,
nobody was getting along,
the director was having
all sorts of problems.
And I thought this thing is doomed.
And I told Scott, I said I can't see
this once it opens it's just going
to be too god-awful.
And he said he'd been working on
it personally then for a long,
long time and he said okay, you
have to come see it at least once,
you have to come to the opening.
And I said oh all right
and it's delightful.
I mean thanks to the director and to
Scott and to editing and everything
that can be done in movies and it's
kind of only in movies it worked.
It's still an unholy mess, but
it's a delightful unholy mess.
So it was -- again, it's the kind
of thing where it's very hard
to duplicate that process to say
okay, how do I take something
in big trouble and save it,
but it sure worked that time.
So it was -- so since then I go
into things thinking you just hope
for the best, see what will work.
But again, nothing -- if
you try too hard to stick
to your original outline or
that image you have in your head
of the finished work you're
doomed, you'll kill yourself.
And because often what you discover
along the way is so much better.
So yeah, so it probably answers --
everything ends up very different.
I remember Jeffrey was originally
called Keep it in Your Pants
and then when I called it
Jeffrey one of the producers,
this wonderful man who's a
heterosexual he told me he said
Paul, I like that title,
I like calling it Jeffrey
because I know it's a gay
play, but I have no idea why.
I thought you are absolutely right.
So again, it's kind
of thing where --
well actually I'll
tell you very quick
that I also wrote Sister Act
originally for Bette Midler
who took many years
and finally said no
because she kept saying
I can't play a nun.
And even though everyone around her
kept saying you're not playing a nun
you're playing a showgirl
disguised as one.
She kept saying no and then it ended
up being made with Whoopi Goldberg
and it became a huge
success, so go figure.
And Bette years later God bless her
came to me and said, why did I turn
that down that was terrible.
And I thought thank you Bette.
But so yeah, so it's just a question
of just staying open
to everything I think.
>> Thank you.
>> Paul Rudnick: You're welcome.
Okay, I've been told
that our time is up.
But again, thank you all
so much for being here.
This has been a delight.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at LOC.gov.